north korea's leader has used his annual
new year's address to warn that his
country may change direction on its
promise of denuclearization
if the united states continues its
sanctions
in his televised speech kim jong-un said
he remained committed to working towards
lasting peace on the korean peninsula
he urged stronger cooperation between
north and south korea
and called on the south to halt its
joint military exercises with the u.s
chairman kim also warned the u.s not to
test his country's patience
i am always ready to sit down again with
the u.s president
at any time and will make efforts to
produce an
outcome that the international community
would welcome
however if the us miscalculates our
people's patience
forces something upon us and pursues
sanctions and pressure without keeping a
promise it made
to the world we have no option but to
explore a new path
in order to protect our sovereignty and
achieve peace
on the korean peninsula
let's get more elements from reuters
correspondent josh smith who joins us
from the south korean capital
a soul uh welcome to dw josh uh what is
this new path
likely to look like
well of course uh many who heard that uh
fear that it could mean worse possibly a
return to
some of the missile tests and launches
that we saw in 2017
and the threats of war from both
pyongyang and washington
but many others given the
emphasis that kim jong-un has placed on
economic development
and more growth for his country see it
as likely that
uh north korean leader kim jong-un is
basically uh setting the stage to blame
washington for any failure of the
denuclearization denuclearization talks
and this allows him basically to turn to
partners like russia
china or even south korea and
potentially
bring them on board as major partners
should things fall through with
washington
so has anything concrete and measurable
been achieved since
kim jong-un and donald trump's historic
summit last june
well while we've seen a fair amount of
inter-korean projects between north and
south korea
going forward there's been far less
progress
between the united states and pyongyang
several high-level talks been cancelled
and have yet to be
rescheduled in his speech kim as you
mentioned
says that he wants to meet with donald
trump again in the new year
and trump has said that he is also
interested in that
and so what this uh what many will be
looking for out of that summit will be
specific some kind of agreement that
both sides can uh
work towards in the future that they
didn't get in their last summit
yeah so each side does appear to be
convinced that the other has done little
to fulfill
previous promises so what do they each
need to see
in order to be convinced
well at the very basic level they need
to have an agreement what they came out
of
from the singapore summit was basically
a series of very broad goals
and that has left a lot to be argued
over since then
and so i think many analysts will be
looking for again specifics out of
uh uh any future meeting an actual
agreement some kind of even limited road
map
um that both sides could potentially
agree on uh
and then compare uh you know progress
good talking to you thanks for joining
us uh josh smith in seoul
thank you